[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de 7,8 échos le magazine consacré à
l'actualité économique de notre
territoire sans plus tarder le sommaire
ils sont un peu plus de 3500 en france
focus dans ce numéro sur les étudiants
entrepreneurs un statut national créé en
2014 à saint quentin en yvelines les
initiatives sont nombreuses pour
encadrer ces jeunes entrepreneurs elle
danielle brahic président de juniors
estaca sera en plateau pour nous
présenter cette association basée à
montigny le bretonneux
c'est un mode de travail dans l'air du
temps que souhaite développer à la
ministre du travail retour sur la visite
de muriel pénicaud 50 comores qui a
amerri enfin notre tour d'horizon de
l'actualité économique dans les yvelines
nous emmènera dans les locaux de la
société à ce mode est à guyancourt
il sera également question à d'un
nouveau club local linkedin est une
vaste opération de recrutement chez une
entreprise bien connue de robots de
cuisine multifonctions
mais avant tous ces titres et bien on va
débuter avec un chiffre à 4000
c'est le nombre d'offres d'emploi
proposées jeudi 29 mars à l'occasion de
la première édition du salon en piste
pour l'emploi un événement organisé par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines au vélodrome nationale avec ap
c est également le nombre de visiteurs
qui ont pu s'informer sur les offres
d'emploi et de formation entre 10h et
22h 200 entreprises du territoire était
également présente en ces périodes de
grève c'est un nouveau mode de travail
qui est privilégié le télétravail
notamment dans les espaces de coworking
et ses espaces de travail partagés se
développe de plus en plus exemple aux 50
comores king amérique qui recevait
vendredi dernier la visite de la
ministre du travail mme muriel pénicaud
les images sont signés michael almy
d'euros ils viennent ici tous les jours
pour certains pour d'autres quelques
heures par semaine à méré depuis
maintenant deux ans et 2050 que working
accueille une cinquantaine de
travailleurs d'un nouveau genre
un nouveau mode de travail que souhaite
déployer le gouvernement pour preuve la
visite la semaine dernière de la mine
straw du travail développer des espaces
de coworking
en france c'est une bonne manière de
permettre ce que ce à quoi aspire 61 %
de nos concitoyens
c'est à dire de faire du télétravail et
en même temps d'avoir cette valeur
ajoutée de l'écosystème et du territoire
230 m² 25 postes de travail ou encore
une salle de réunion pour les
utilisateurs du 50 corps king ce nouveau
mode de travail présente plusieurs
avantages qu au niveau de qualité de vie
en est quand même beaucoup mieux en
télétravail puisqu'on travaille proche
de chez nous et donc au niveau du stress
et tout ça ça réduit vraiment ces
difficultés là et puis on est on est
bien mieux quand on rentre le soir à la
maison
en fait moi je suis indépendant je
pourrais être encore une fois tout seul
j'ai bien sûr les relations avec mes
clients mais ça ne suffit pas en fait
donc je viens chercher ici une vraie un
brin un vrai lien communautaire puisque
un simple bureau un esprit collaboratif
des valeurs essentielles pour cet espace
de coworking situées en zone rurale
le but c'est de garder une taille
humaine aussi qui permet de maintenir ce
lien et cette convivialité
j'ai pas d'ambition
d'agrandissement ou de multiplication
des sites
par contre j'ai une ambition
d'accompagnement sur la création
d'autres espaces de coworking et
d'autres tiers lieu que ce soit sur mon
territoire ou sur le reste du territoire
national durant les prochaines semaines
la ministre du travail mme muriel
pénicaud va multiplier les déplacements
en ile de france sur la question du
télétravail et des espaces de coworking
fois que sa présence sur le statut
d'étudiant entrepreneur lancé il ya
quatre ans par le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur on compte
aujourd'hui un peu plus de 3500
étudiants en france ayant ce statut sur
le territoire de paris saclay mais aussi
au sein de levier ce qu de nombreux
dispositifs existent reportage kenny et
selim suivent un master à l'institut
supérieur de management de guyancourt
mais ce soir au ski cube c'est en tant
qu'entrepreneur qu'il s'exprime devant
une cinquantaine de personnes
ils présentent leurs projets de startups
à l'occasion de la saq les pitchs night
ce serait de faire un lien entre donc
les pme et les utilisateurs de
téléphones et d'utiliser les coques en
tant que qu'outil outils de publicité de
et de communication on a déjà lancé une
étude de marché côté utilisateur d'un
côté client et là par contre on a des
retours très positifs donc les grandes
prochaine étape c'est sonder les
entreprises et puis après valider tout
business plan trois minutes pour exposer
son idée de projet d'entreprise c'est le
principe de cet événement un exercice de
communication organisées régulièrement
par l'association starting saclay
destiné aux étudiants elle a pour but de
promouvoir l'entrepreneuriat sur le
territoire de paris saclay ils viennent
surtout s'entraîner au pitch rencontrer
d'autres gens puisqu'on a un petit
cocktail networking après et ils
viennent aussi collecté donc du coût des
retours de new start i saclay ou de ceux
qui nous invite par exemple en eau sky
cube donc le personnel jusqu'à la cub
viendra donner ces retours sur les
pitchs witcher lancé il ya quatre ans
par le ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur le statut étudiant
entrepreneur est porté par une trentaine
de pôle étudiant à travers la france sur
notre territoire il s'agit du réseau
peps a lu vs qu il est possible de
concilier sa vie d'étudiant et sa vie de
jeune entrepreneur grâce à un
accompagnement mon travail en fait c'est
d'être un premier guichet pour les aider
à évaluer leurs projets de façon un
petit peu professionnelle puisque
moi-même chance et entrepreneurs et de
les diriger vers toutes les instances
les autres organismes qui pourraient les
aider à accélérer leurs projets à faire
de la communication tous les étudiants
de la licence première année au doctorat
sont de futurs potentiels entrepreneurs
l'entrepreneuriat c'est très agglo stick
de l'âge de la provenance sociale ou du
diplôme et donc il faut pas hésiter dès
qu'on a envie à passer à l'action et à
essayer de structurer ses projets
justement sont passés à l'action
ruben et françois tous deux doctorants
en météorologie se sont lancés dans
l'aventuré entrepreneuriale avec leur
startup hd rain n'est de travaux de
recherche au sein du latmos le
laboratoire de l'ue vs qu elle a pour
vocation de mesurer et de prévoir les
précipitations à haute définition
le but c'est de faire de
de la mesure et de la prévision de pluie
qui va nous permettre de mettre en place
des produits d' alerte en cas de très
fortes précipitations et de risques
d'inondations éclairs et des produits d'
aide à la gestion de la ressource en eau
sera à destination des principalement
des pays en voie de développement
pour l'instant c'est encore à l'état de
prototype on a un démonstrateur avec
avec déjà quatre capteurs qui tourne en
temps réel sur la ville de toulouse on
continue à les déployer en ce moment
donc pour que ça marche il s'agit
d'installer une parabole de réception de
la télé comme ça et puis un petit
boîtier électronique pas plus gros que
ça a lu vs qu on compte pour l'instant
une dizaine d'étudiants ayant le statut
d'étudiant entrepreneurs et m'a rejoint
sur ce plateau daniel brèque bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le président de
juniors estaca c'est une association qui
est implanté au sein de l'estac à
l'école supérieure des techniques
aéronautiques de construction automobile
vous êtes basé à montigny le bretonneux
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire plus sur cette association tout à
fait donc on est une association de loi
1901 avec la particularité d'être
fiscalisés et on est scindé en deux
parties donc une partie des étudiants
administrateurs une partie d'étudiants
réalisateur et on va accompagner en fait
les porteurs de projets qui ce que ce
soit des grands comptes ou bien des
entrepreneurs qui veulent se lancer à
concrétiser leurs projets et à
travailler sur des missions qui sont
rémunérés votre association alors on est
25 étudiants administrateurs et on
travaille chaque année avec une
trentaine d'étudiants réalisateur alors
qu'est ce que vous proposez concrètement
alors concrètement on va proposer tout
ce qu'on apprend à l'estaca donc
l'ingénierie qui est porté sur les
transports on peut penser notamment la
conception le prototypage et
l'industrialisation
c'est globalement les corps de métiers
on propose aussi des activités de
programmation et on tend à développer le
conseil et la formation puisque c'est
possible pendant alors combien
d'entreprises par c'est une association
rappelle qui existe depuis plus de
trente ans et que ça
parents combien d'entreprises font appel
alors en 2007 on a travaillé avec quinze
entreprises
donc on peut on pouvait compter des
grands comptes notamment dans
l'automobile et le ferroviaire et des
porteurs de projets des entrepreneurs
qui qui veulent se lancer
alors comment ça se passe entreprises
donc vous sollicite tout à fait alors on
a un un département de prospection et de
développement commercial
donc on peut aller chercher les
entreprises mais on a surtout de la
visibilité sur internet puisque il
suffit de venir sur notre site internet
et de déposer en quelques lignes son
projet vers quoi on tend quel est le
contexte et nous derrière on se cherche
de recontacter la personne est d'établir
ensemble une proposition commerciale
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner un
exemple sans citer forcément
l'entreprise à un exemple de projet vous
avez mené en 2000 est tout à fait alors
on a travaillé avec un entrepreneur qui
souhaitait réaliser un robot donc
c'était une mission de conception mais
également de prototypage on a aussi
travaillé avec un grand compte du
ferroviaire pour une mission de
déploiement d'un logiciel au niveau
national et cette mission est un succès
également alors finalement quels sont
les avantages pour une entreprise de
faire appel à junior estaca plutôt
qu'une autre entreprise qui proposerait
on va dire les mêmes services l'avantagé
c'est de travailler avec des étudiants
donc qui ont une vision assez novatrice
et qui n'est pas forcément celle qu'on a
une fois qu'on a un bagage dans une
entreprise est évidemment il ya aussi
l'aspect financier qui est intéressant
pour une entreprise puisque nous ne
sommes pas des professionnels
donc nous ne pouvons pas prétendre à la
même heure même pas curation vous parler
d'argent justement
c'est une association vous avez un
chiffre d'affaires tout à fait de en
2017 on a réalisé un chiffre d'affaires
de plus de 40 mille euros et
donc on est fiscalisé ça sous-entend
qu'on qu'on paie des impôts sociaux mais
également fiscaux et comme une
entreprise traditionnelle finalement
vous le disais il ya donc les étudiants
donc qui qui sont au service et j'avais
venir j'allais dire administratif donc
vous vous faites ça bénévolement si ça
et puis les étudiants justement qui il
travaille sur les sur les demandes et
des entreprises donc ces étudiants là
sont rémunérés tout à fait on est
structuré donc comme une entreprise au
sein de l'administration
on a une trésorerie on a des ressources
humaines on a un pôle communication un
pôle qualité et surtout un pôle de
développement commercial et du côté des
étudiants ont leur revers ce qu'on
appelle des honoraires puisque ce sont
des intervenants pour juniors estaca et
outre l'aspect financier c'est surtout
un aspect pédagogique qu'on leur apporte
puisqu'on leur permet de toucher du
doigt le monde professionnel et des
exigences qu'on les professionnels une
dernière question comment sont
sélectionnés ces étudiants qui vont
mener à bien les projets alors on
travaille régulièrement avec des
étudiants auxquels on a déjà fait appel
mais on a un service de ressources
humaines qui se charge de les recruter
parmi les 1500 étudiants du campus de
saint quentin en yvelines de l'estaca
merci à daniel brèque pour toutes ces
précisions bien sûr on vous retrouve en
sueur à sur internet celui de la sépaq a
point comme une entreprise de jeux de
société qui ne cesse de se développer à
guyancourt une marque de robots de
cuisine multifonctions qui organisait
une vaste opération de recrutement ou
encore un nouveau club lookéa linkedin à
50 ans ont nivelé
c'est tout de suite dans l'actualité
économique en bref réunir les acteurs de
la vie économique saint-quentinoise
voilà l'objectif du nouveau club local
linkedin de saint quentin en yvelines
à l'origine les deux associés de la
société ftc digitalité m
amorphes a annoncé l'expérience y a
maintenant on va dire un mois on se rend
compte que quand on est sur ce réseau là
les gens n'échange pas réellement en
visuel on est juste plus tôt dans le
dans le virtuel j'ai été moi il ya
quelques années
demandeurs d'emploi et je me suis rendu
compte que c'était compliqué de
d'échanger avec des gens quand on
n'avait pas de réseau pour la prochaine
soirée prévue en mai les fondateurs du
club attendent 200 personnes
c'est un robot cuiseur multifonction qui
a révolutionné le monde de la cuisine
selon ses adeptes pour dénicher les
futurs vendeurs de cet outil qui a la
particularité d'être vendus uniquement à
domicile les agences thermomix ont
récemment organisé une grande journée de
recrutement elle c'était le cas
notamment à bois d'arcy dans les
yvelines 80 postes de vendeurs à
domicile ou de vrp et est à pourvoir
dans le département on n'a pas besoin de
diplôme particulier on vient parce qu'on
a envie qu'on aime qu'on a les valeurs
du culinaire donc le partage la
convivialité
j'irai c'est plus ça qui fait qu'on
vient chez nous parce qu'il a une
ambiance des valeurs humaines fortes
plutôt que des diplômes
implantée à guillon pour la société
asmodée n'en finit plus de se développer
leader européen des jeux de société le
siège s'étend désormais sur douze mille
mètres carrés un terrain vendu par saint
quentin en yvelines d'où cette récente
visite avec les élus locaux
avec un catalogue de plus de 2000
références à ce mode est affiché en 2010
est un chiffre d'affaires de 450
millions d'euros
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi à 17
avril pour un nouveau 7 8 et qu à très
bientôt
[Musique]